- [Voiceover] Grammarians,
we're gonna talk about
relative pronouns today
and what relative pronouns
do is they link clauses together,
specifically, independent
and dependent clauses,
and if you don't know what independent
and dependent clauses are, that's okay,
just, suffice it to say,
that these pronouns allow you
to staple phrases together.
For example, in the sentence,
the man who sold the world
is coming by on Tuesday, the pronoun who,
is the relative pronoun there,
it's linking the independent clause,
the man is coming by on Tuesday
to the dependent clause, sold the world.
The relative pronouns of
English are who, whom,
whose, that and which, and we use them all
for different things.
So, we can use who, whom, whose and that
to refer to people, and we can use
whose, that and which to refer to things.
Let me show you.
You could say, the salad
that I bought was wilted.
But at the same time, I can
also use that in this sentence.
The man that I saw smiled.
See, I'm using that to refer to him.
I could also use who, but the word which,
however, does not play
very nicely with people.
In the sentence, the witch
who cast the spell is kind,
we could use either the
witch who cast the spell
or the witch that cast the spell because
both that and who work with people.
But which, strangely, does not.
So we couldn't say, for example, the witch
which owns a cat is cruel.
That's just now how
the language shook out,
which is not a relative
pronoun that applies to people.
These are the relative
pronouns of English,
this is broadly how
they work and I'm gonna
get into more specifics
in following videos.
You can learn anything, David out.